what's going on guys happy new year it's
and that means two things we're getting
hoverboards this year and one of the
greatest movie slates in recent memory
is about to drop on us and we've got an
awesome panel to break it down with a
couple of New Year's babies right here
first he's a writer for slash film he's
been with us a number of times before
our good friend Jermaine Lussier now
good to see you buddy
happy new year oh good to have you I'm
glad you stumbled here you're sleeping
awake all night been a rough night and
you know that's why I'm gonna sweat it
oh she's one of the faces of AMC movie
talk and you know her from the schmoes
know Alicia Malone
this year I'm definitely gonna work out
I resolved this year you see a bunch of
awesome movies yeah let me ask each of
you individually what are you looking
forward to most Alicia let's start with
you well if you ask me least a few
months ago we're giving you a different
answer but now Mad Max fury road after
seeing those trailers yeah incredible
it is so greasy and dirty and that
George Miller trailer was like poetic
with the music to come sent and made the
special effects it looks like it
actually hits so it feels like those
steaks with the action scenes yeah and
not wait to say that Jermaine which one
are you looking for it's the hack answer
buts The Force awakens I mean it's just
it's all I've been thinking about since
October 2013 when Disney bought it and
they said Star Wars 7 was coming it's
all I've been thinking about every day
it's the start of a whole new era Star
Wars what film are you most nervous of
the house Wow well I think I think again
I get what the heck answers Jurassic
world
I never thought was gonna see another
Jurassic Park movie and we got one and
it's it's Colin Trevorrow who has made
one great movie but it's so scary to
have a guy that jumps from a really
small movie like safe not guaranteed to
Jurassic world I'm super nervous about
it okay yeah I'm not sure how that's
gonna work out because I love that
you're right I know yeah we excited to
see him take on this Peyton Reed yeah
they definitely rushed it through but at
the same time Peyton Reed is the kind of
director who I think might have been
able to embrace that what's the movie
that not a lot of people are talking
about
but you think could sneak up and
surprise us Alicia well I would say the
hateful eight Quentin Tarantino I'm a
huge Tarantino fan this was the movie
that got leaked online so he wasn't
gonna make it yeah man now he is it's a
revenge Weston
I love Django Unchained so more bounty
hunters this time Civil War I'm in I
have to I to that I'm gonna do real fast
right inside out the next Pixar movie
yeah these are the guys who've made some
of the greatest animated movies of all
time this movie has such a great concept
I think it's gonna be awesome
the other one I think people are talking
about yet is Tomorrowland which is Brad
Birds movie written co-written by Damon
Lindelof but George Clooney and it's
about this alternate dimension where as
a futuristic thing that the trailer was
really good really good tease yeah
really striking teaser it just has this
it's this really cool air of mystery
it's coming out over a Memorial Day
weekend that's pretty huge you know like
I think they have some really good
confidence in it it should be cool all
right let's start breaking it down kind
of section off these films first let's
start with the why a film so the young
adult novels are gonna have a battery
here this year end of the Hunger Games
divergent and Maze Runner which one are
we looking forward to most I think out
of those three definitely really looking
forward to see it end properly
Mockingjay part 1 felt like a little bit
of a setup so I can't wait for
everything to be completed and in
Mockingjay part 2 Maze Runner I'm not
interested in because that committed the
cardinal sin of cinema the first one
which is it is purely a setup for the
sequel there's going to be a new
Blomkamp movie chappie yeah are we
looking forward to that I'm interested
I'm interested in it I mean I didn't
like what was Lucien Elysium so
forgettable it was a cool concept it
felt like the studio really got involved
and distract him from doing what he
really wanted to do so hopefully with
Jaffe he can it sounds really cute yeah
yeah like an AI robot who gets like you
know taken and starts like blowing stuff
up like I'm cool like Neill Blomkamp he
made district I know I'm in for anything
now let's talk about secret agents for a
second some of our favorites mission
impossible 5 mi5 and mi6 speaking of the
British see James Bond and the Kings
so alright Kingsman I think it's gonna
be the first one release yeah I've heard
awesome things about it everything
trailers look badass
it looks great Matthew Vaughn directing
and he has such great production design
so it just looks so cool and I love
Colin Firth mr. Darcy and I love I like
Mark Millar's style he's based on his
comic books and he always is really
interesting fun like self-aware stories
yeah the this movie looks really cool
comes out yeah in February and I've
heard really good things where people
who seemed already in the bond Victor
they 24th bond i love bond and the fact
that Sam Mendes is coming back to
director Skyfall was one of my favorite
modern bonds yeah I wait to see what he
does for this one let's talk about an
all-american secret agent Ethan Hunt I
can't believe they're been fought I mean
it's gonna be tough to top the fourth
one because I thought ghost Protocol is
really great Bradford we mentioned with
Tomorrowland we don't know anything
about it you know really so you just
have to you know put your faith in the
crews you know yeah I mean Tom Cruise
the guy knows how to be a movie star I
feel like I never quite believed him as
anyone else but Tom Cruise like I always
see Tom Cruise but I'm willing to go
with him wherever he goes yeah I love
him as a hero okay I think the headline
for this year sequels so many damn
sequels in or out on Furious 7 big jump
in okay so in I'd love to franchise
since the first movie James Wan who did
the conjuring his first big action movie
my problem with these sails I love them
they're silly and they're fun and since
number five I think they really embrace
this is yes yes it's just some of the
action scenes they're unbelievable now
they just have to keep going more more
like Vin Diesel can't fly according to
the yeah yeah according to the movies
Vin Diesel is an angel
shortly after Furious 7 hits the
theaters Avengers 2 age of Ultron my
second most anticipated movie yes before
was the number one Star Wars actually
it's Avengers now Alicia let me ask you
you said Mad Max was number one right
now but Avengers or Star Wars Star Wars
because I love the original films I'm
not super into comic books so I don't
know the characters but I think the
comic book movies can be really good
yeah the trailer
Tron looks great I love James Spader as
the voice I think that's a great casting
choice but I'm not it's not on my list
of top ten anticipated movies let's just
start throwing them out there and jump
on it with any thoughts Fifty Shades of
Grey no I've never read it don't care
very unsexy trailer for something that's
supposed to be super sexy well a long
way to Jupiter ascending Channing Tatum
Wachowski siblings nervous about this
one because of all the delays and the
trailer doesn't look so good
but chattington with pointing ears maybe
the Wachowski is doing huge sci-fi I'm
kind of cautiously very excited about it
I don't think we've talked about
terminator yet no yeah I don't know it's
worried but I hope it's good yeah I'm
not sure I wasn't sold on the trailer I
think the concept is really confusing I
don't know what the Y is doing in there
Jai Courtney and I think he's really
pretty and just yeah yeah I'm not sure
huge movie that we I don't think we've
seen any footage for it yet fantastic or
yeah I'm just I like the actors josh
trank as director i mean it's a chronic
was great he's got a Star Wars movie
based off of this yeah you know so
that's encouraging but the fact that you
know the movie comes out in August and
we've seen nothing there's some spy
photos here and there no trailers no
still no poster you know that worries me
like why are they holding back but it's
it's you hold out hope another sequel
coming up - kind of a surprise comedy
hit Ted
- how many sequels are so hard - they
are because it's hard to replicate the
magic of the first one because you got
to give them the same of what the
audience wants but then something new at
the same time and it was such a great
shock value seeing the bear the first
time around I don't know how they can
replicate it but it was really funny we
talked about inside out Pixar's another
movie coming up this year the good
dinosaur this movie was supposed to come
out like two years ago or a year ago I
don't remember but it was delayed so
you're worried about that but at the
same time it's Pixar you know it's it's
it's a great idea where what if what if
dinosaurs did go extinct they would
still be running the planet and we'd be
the pets what a cool idea for a movie I
think we've hit just about every major
movie this year is there one that we
haven't mentioned that come a year from
now January 1st 2016
we're all like man we didn't see that
game-changer coming
I saw a trailer for a film called the
walk which is Robert Zemeckis it's based
on the tightrope walker the French guy
who in the 70s walked between the two
Twin Towers Philippe Petit yes
SARS Joseph gordon-levitt and the
trailer doesn't show much but it's gonna
be in IMAX and the heights I'm terrified
of heights yeah and it looks incredible
great documentary about that man know
why oscar-winning yeah for me this is
Chris Columbus movie called pixels it's
coming out and it's an Adam Sandler
movie but already like oh no I don't
wanna be but the concept is so cool
where aliens attack us with giant
oversized old-school videogame
characters so pac-man and space invaders
like Independence Day coming down and
crushing everybody and who has saved the
world the Nerds played by Peter Dinklage
Josh GAD and Adam Sandler directed by
Chris Columbus who did home alone and
the PI refers to very Potter's I think
that could be really fun
what are you most excited for this year
let us know in the comments below best
answer oh we're gonna send you of my
screen junkies t-shirt again I want to
wish you a Happy New Year and I want to
wish a Happy New Year to this wonderful
panel and thank you for coming in and
talking movies with us Jermaine Lussier
/ film and Alicia Malone AMC movie talk
schmoes know she is just a blessing from
Down Under
thanks guys thank you for watching I'm
how rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
[Music]
I waited for that reaction I purpose see
I bring things to the table that I know
are controversial so far you like that
if you know I like a bad opinion bad
opinion